Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here.
If you've watched my review of Moana, you'll
know I really enjoyed the animated feature.
So, in this video, I want to look at the five
funniest moments from the film.
Obviously, there are spoilers ahead if you
haven't seen the film already!
And if that's you, you can check out my spoiler-free
review of the movie here, and come back and
watch this video after you've seen it!
By the way, I've got a fab giveaway to win
this gorgeous Art of Moana hardback book.
It'll be on my Moana Easter Egg video, so
make sure you subscribe and I'll add a link
here to the video when it's ready.
Kicking us off at number five is the scene
where Maui steals Moana's boat and sails off,
even taking along Moana's rooster side-kick,
Heihei, as a snack for later!
It's especially funny when Moana escapes from
the cave where the trickster demi-god trapped
her and launches herself into the air to try
and catch up with Maui on the boat, but just
misses it and lands splat in the sea.
And I love how Maui reacts, saying, 'I could
watch that all day.
Ok, enjoy the island.
Maui out!', then he tries to get away, but
the ocean has other ideas and carries Moana
back on to the canoe again and again, despite
Maui's repeated attempts to get rid of her!
It's just a little slapstick scene, but it's
still very amusing when Heihei stows away
on Moana's boat and she finds him once they've
set sail.
That moment is so funny when Moana takes the
half-coconut shell off Heihei's head and he
realises where he actually is, not on dry
land with rocks to peck and swallow, but surrounded
by water in the middle of the ocean, and he
lets out a piercing scream, which only stops
each time Moana puts the coconut shell back
on his head!
I love the magnificently crazy action scene
where a boat-load of teeny-tiny pirates wearing
armour made of coconut shells attack Moana
and Maui on the high seas!
There's so many of them that they're absolutely
everywhere, zip-lining on to Moana's boat,
swiping Heihei who's swallowed the heart of
Te Fiti, and suddenly turning their one ship
into three!
There's loads of fun in this fast-paced scene,
including the Kakamoras accidentally shooting
their chief with a blow-dart!
And Moana gets some bad-ass action fighting
the coconutty pirates, as does Maui who sails
their boat through the ever-narrowing gap
between two rapidly merging Kakamora vessels!
It's all very Mad Max: Fury Road.
And who can forget when Moana first meets
Maui?!
Thanks to an exceptionally charismatic performance
by Dwayne Johnson, who lends his voice to
the big-headed, big-muscled demi-god.
Maui's so full of himself that not only does
he stop Moana mid-speech to make sure she
gets his full title correct.
"It's actually Maui, Shapeshifter, Demi-God
of the Wind and Sea, Hero of Men.
I interrupeted, from the top.
Hero of Men.
Go"
but he also assumes that what she really wants
is his autograph, because, he is, after all,
'hero of men… and women…
it's not a guy-gal thing'.
Also, I really love 'You're Welcome, the totally
irresistible song he sings about all his amazing
accomplishments and why he thinks humankind
must be so grateful to him.
And the whole scene is made even better by
the way Maui's tattoos come to life to tell
the story of all his fantastic feats, and
the way mini-Maui acts as his voice of reason.
Absolutely adore it!
And at number one is the frankly fabulous
scene where Moana and Maui outwit the totally
blinged-up, colossally conceited crab Tamatoa
on their mission to get Maui's magical fishhook
back.
I love everything about this bit of the film,
especially the incredibly catchy David Bowie-style
song that Tamatoa sings about how amazing
he is.
I also love the way the 50-foot crab suddenly
appears out of what just looked like a pile
of treasure and how Moana cleverly tricks
him by showering him with compliments, appealing
to the fact that he just adores bragging about
himself.
And it's really funny how Tamatoa does a sort
of running commentary about what's going on
and also how Maui swoops in and grabs back
his hook, telling Tamatoa that 'it's Maui
time'!
Jemaine Clement, who voices the super-sized
crustacean, is just perfect and wrings every
last drop of comedy out of the scene, which
is why it's great to see Tamatoa on screen
again in a comical post-credits scene where
he name-drops Sebastian from The Little Mermaid.
It is just brilliant!
Ok, what are your favourite moments from Moana?
And which bits made you laugh out loud the
most?
Can't wait to read your comments below!
I've got videos on the way with all the easter
eggs and hidden mickeys in Moana plus some
cool deleted scenes from the movie, and I'll
update the link here once they're live!
If you enjoyed this video, thanks for hitting
the thumbs-up and share buttons, and don't
forget to hit that subscribe button for more
videos on Disney, Pixar, comic book movies,
and more!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!